what do you think I want a little 100 lb
thing I think you would like be able to
match her in a way but I would be
dominated I don't even know why I said
that on
[Music]
camera hey welcome back everybody to
another awesome episode of the careful
boys where like Steve says we are afraid
of everything that being said here is
the situation if a Freaky Friday thing
was going down right where you woke up
in someone else's body oh who would you
like to be for a day and have them
inhabit your body oh they got to my body
that's Freaky Friday bro yeah but then
what do I get where do I go why where do
I park my soul while someone's in here
that's literally the prompt you choose
who do you who would you choose oh like
we swap like that hypothetically yeah
but it has to be that pair because you
get to inhabit their body but they get
to inhabit
yours what do you do some LeBron James
stuff and just feel what it is to be
like a specimen oh
wow totally fine with LeBron being you
yeah I didn't have a wife or nothing cuz
I was thinking that way you're a winner
right cuz if I had a wife and then
LeBron's in my body and bangs my wife
that feels bad kind of cool though it's
cool but not like he has to use my
equipment which is a little different
than what he's used to which makes it
less painful for sure yeah my wife
wouldn't know what's going on it
wouldn't be changing her life actually
he's probably less talented right cuz if
you have the equipment he doesn't have
to get as creative he doesn't know what
to do with I don't have the equipment so
you get real creative I think you should
build off the Assumption and try and
Define let me ask you this so he's
probably got a huge
[__] so he's probably not a good lover
if you swap with your wife and then you
[__] yourself is that masturbation or
are you
gay that's gay I think you're gay yeah
yeah that's gay think that makes you gay
oh that's so disgusting you get to enjoy
what she feel can you imagine so imagine
this you get to enjoy what she feels and
then you could be like oh I a good [__]
imag don't move me you don't have to
move me no no no imagine you're looking
at yourself that's disgusting help the
visual that's weird I don't want to do
that [__] I think being a lady a lady
boss would be cool like a celebrity
which one I don't even know you want to
be a woman you should be you would
switch with the
woman yeah like a JLo JLo dude but then
the same thing going to be a little gay
yeah they like cuz sex is guaranteed
every day I no but you have the power to
be like no no bed she for sure wears the
pants in that relationship or you could
be Jennifer Love hu and just play with
their boobs all day that's true 24 hours
I want to be a lesbian woman I think I
think she got the hack that's five head
yeah but then when you become a woman do
you go oh girls cuz in your no no no
you're you you're you yeah you're still
horny yeah you're still just a horny
gross man what if you immediately feel
all the wom hormones and everything see
and then you're just like oh cuz all
guys be like first thing I'm going do is
play with my clitoris that's what the
clitoris is based on science that's what
Little Dicky did I believe it's going to
happen who the [__] Lil Dicky you
don't know Lil Dicky holy [__] this
guy's probably like cousins with L Dicky
that's what I got Lil Dicky a
lot he's a Jewish man jewi little dick
is a dude who wrapped Freaky Friday with
Chris Brown they swap bodies so he woke
up and he started saying the M bomb
everywhere and then at the very end of
the music video he swaps with I think
Kylie Jenner or something like that so
he starts spaming himself she's in the
video going his Show's kind of
underrated his Show's amazing yeah it's
pretty good wait did he do dick in the
Box no no no that was JT yeah but he did
a lot of funny music videos he's got
like lyrical Talent as a rapper but he's
more like humorous he's brilliant you
don't really don't know look he does dud
I'm [__] old no it was our generation
yeah he's old I think you would
appreciate Little Dicky you'd like the
show for sure too we we would study that
[__] for like JK parodies and [__] so
he's been around that long no yeah he's
OG like 10 years ago yeah he's [__]
you that music video where he like
walked up to a bunch of people's houses
and then he filmed a music video in like
15 minutes or some [__] I think he
didn't pay for him he literally asked if
he can use
their and then he filmed his whole music
video he's kind of a YouTuber really
yeah I think he started as a tuber yeah
he's cool where'd that go oh the Freaky
Friday yeah Freaky Friday he said Freaky
Friday cuz I think every every generic
as like if I woke up as a girl I [__]
mastbate uh raise your hand if you would
do that yeah but then what's the next
stage [__] a dude right a lesbian could
H pass for gay he always goes right to
gay I might try it I just spend the 24
hours playing with my titties and
[__] fingering myself and then just
like you said earlier why don't you just
choose a lesbian shake or do you do like
the baller stuff right I do like a Saudi
Prince and I literally am like showering
in Gold Oh I thought you were going to
poop on a girl I thought you were you
would do a Saudi Prince no no no I would
freak Friday dude if I became a Saudi
Prince I think he'd probably like beat
up my wife or something he'd probably be
really mean to my wife oh yeah because
it's a swap rusi that's true you know
what I would do I would I would wrap my
wife in in like like a bunch of football
pads and stuff like that and then I
would switch
B but I'd be like babe you just got to
make it 24 hours right just just go just
leave the house just leave the house and
then when I'm in the Saudi princess body
I'm like sending myself Bitcoin and [__]
I know what my [__] Bitcoin address
that's that's it actually you're just
wiring money yeah for a [__] 24 hours
I'm wiring myself all this money that's
genius what if you get to swap but you
don't even to get to choose so you like
Swap and then the first thing you do is
you're trying to someone's trying to
assassinate you within your family and
extend extended relative so they can
gain power and you're just like what the
[__] man the whole time we just trying
to Sur and then there's gay butt sex
yeah exactly and then you realize you're
like man being a satic prince was
actually way more complicated and I had
it all wrong I was wrong I learned a
real lesson about this stuff I'm going
to give him his Bitcoin back that is the
Disney Channel version of this whole
Freaky Friday thing wow I never seen it
like that through his shoes wow so crazy
wow we are all flesh we're all the same
wow Human Experience crazy he he flies
to my house and then we hug on my on my
foot on my foot footstep and then we
stay in touch and we become buds I want
be an Egyptian pharaoh hey but oh we can
time travel too I guess I made that
up no that' be F yeah Hercules or some
[__] would be cool yeah yeah yeah cuz
one if he was real back in those days
they didn't have no Geneva Convention
[__] yeah so they didn't have the
Geneva
Convention and we really don't know what
their culture was like right talk about
you're talking about being an Egyptian
god a pharaoh it's almost like you have
500 people carrying a stone and making a
pyramid out maybe maybe they are
aliens we don't know we don't know the
math doesn't work out them shits was
Heavy I want I might be part alien we
don't have that's actually more likely
what if you could yeah swap out with the
little green thing that means a part's
going to come to you right now and
they're going to do some wild things for
sure butt sex no yes that's not proven
there's no hieroglyph of [__] doggy
Al going to come back and do butt sex
then you're going to [__] find humans
carrying pyramid blocks yeah if the
Spartans had butt sex the Egyptians had
butt sex and you're all about Spartan
butt sex but no I'm not no I think it's
been a thing it's real it's real they I
think we're missing out yeah why what's
wrong with our culture and
pedia it's pedophilic something tells me
no matter what body Joe switched with
there would be butt sex that's what I'm
saying not to me gay things in
butt I'm not trying to it's history it's
the first thing you always list no I
don't hey would you want to be would you
want to swap bodies with Prince oh yeah
that' be a good there guar
but he's not gay bro what is he an alien
no he [__] the hottest girl and where's
the hottest men where I don't know I
know there's no Prince hieroglyph
everyone just accused him of being gay
he took out his ribs so he could suck
his own dick I thought Marilyn
Manson okay I would be just hearing that
in today's year like oh my hear me out
me out Carmen
Electra before she got with Dennis Ramen
that's probably my all time Crush when
he discovered her she was the hatest
because she was untainted and then he
was kmen Electra might be my dream woman
so you're saying you're going to get
[__] by Dennis
Rodman no I don't want to be Carmen
Electra I'm PR [__] car Electra
Electra in Scary Movie or whatever oh
with the sprinklers and the mhm I think
I might swap with my mom
okay just like to see if if all the [__]
she [__] complains about if it's
really that stressful when you swap with
her you just have her body but her like
Day Life yeah like a day don't I live
her life yeah but are you going to
actually know where to go and what to
and that's your one choice you got one
day to do this you swapping with your
mom would just be like your daily life
it's your mom yelling at you so you
would just be your mom yelling at you
again she would call you as you yeah
yeah she'd be like why you swat body and
you're like calm the [__] down as me
yeah she' be like but I'm you what
happened she's not going to have an
accent cuz she's going to be in my body
now you have an accent either way you're
getting yelled at you're getting yelled
at by your mom either way that's the
best part yelling just with a deeper
voice it's probably going to be that
fun
[__] but that was an interesting answer
cuz I like I was thinking like who
[__] complains all the [__] time
and I want to see if it's really that
stressful her [__] life your mom
complains a lot all the time she [__]
text me like my mom she wants your
attention bro so my mom will [__] she
she hired a Chinese contractor to
[__] rewire the AC Ducks out her
office because she like oh it's [__]
blowing wind or whatever I want to go to
her office and see if it's [__]
blowing wind is just catching pneumonia
isn't that what AC ducks are supposed to
do that's what we supposed to do to blow
wind but the way my mom takes it it's
[__] crazy it would have been much
cheaper to wear a big hat and a coat
true okay I will say at least that's the
first scenario that butt sex probably
isn't involved and I'll applaud you for
that thank you good
job but I but the first thing that came
to my mind and I was like why' you want
to be your mom jacking off all day
that's kind of weird yeah you want to
feel your mom's did you raise your hand
when we said we're touching ourselves
cuz that's if I Jennifer Love H it
Jennifer Love hu it I'm touching myself
all day very fair but that ends in butt
sex for sure but if I I never once said
butt sex you guys put butts in my mouth
you've been saying I put butt sex in
your mouth said was what if you [__]
yourself that g that's correct no that's
correct editor please repeat that it's
not butt sex I'm a woman getting drilled
by me would you want to do that my wife
swapped I'm Hannah on the floor [__] me
[__] me Daddy and then I'm the one
looking myself and I and then I can tell
if I'm actually good at sex or not would
you want this
deep I think your [__] would dry out
seeing yourself [__] up see that's gay
I don't think you get in the mood what
if you go swap up with Carmen Electra we
swap up with kmen Electra then you go
find yourself and let yourself [__] you
oh that's gay but that's kind of fun you
better to look yourself in the eyes
doggy doggy doggy no that's not how it
doggy no eyes because she's you now
right so then I'm [__] Electra like
twice no you got to understand that when
you find her a swap she's traumatized
cuz she's [__] suddenly judges C she
sees her own self and she freaks out she
passes out she's not going to want to
[__] that maybe though cuz then she
might want to [__] herself she might be
in the same sick mindset as I am right
now what if what if cuz you're cuz
she'll be like oh what's it like to [__]
me she's not lesbian though you're going
to be hurt for 24 hours right yeah okay
so what I do is I I I'm Caron Electra
right I take her to my house and I lock
myself in the basement and then the next
oh that's probably huh
H B all right that's part that's where I
[__] up yeah I walked my you're
thinking about the 25th hour yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah the 25th hour I swap back
I know where K elra is the 25th hour
yeah 25th hour she's Steve that's a
movie too so she'll she's Steve so she'd
be unlocking the door for you but you
know what I would say no he does it and
then he saves her oh that's kind of pimp
and now I'm big cuz she will never know
what you look like oh actually she'll
look in the no she will know what you
look like yeah she will like why is elro
my yeah that's right doesn't work this
stuff is complicated it's like time
Trel there's repercussions we don't even
know about Butterfly Effect he's like
why is karma electric grabbing my ass
and humping me in the kitchen this is
very weird that's kind of hot but you
film it you film it you have that for
later I like
that an off I was thinking the bank I
was thinking the
bank that's not
gay what's not gay get a video camera
you're Karma Electra you [__] your wife
as karma Electra okay and film it you
film it that's actually the play 24
hours later life hack spank bank but
your girl got to be into Karma Electra
true I think all girls are you have to
convince her that it's you at the time
this is definitely us talking as guys
right now if you got to convince her
it's you if she knows and you have 24
hours to [__] her yeah we got 20 hours
to convince her 3 hours to depends how
hot the girl is right you need 3 minutes
no dude you're a girl now oh
hours yeah you could definitely last
it's a lot of build up for like 8
minutes but yeah but it's going to rock
your world at 8 minutes and then and
then you switch back cuz the 24th hour
happened and then suddenly now your wife
wants to leave you cuz she lesbian oh
she might be gone for good yeah she's
like I found better if you were in
someone else's body do you think it'd be
easy to convince Nina that you're you
why you always got to put names into it
like that you know make it all I could
name other names don't do that that's
not good either [__] okay it'd be so
easy for me to convince Nikki I think so
me too repeat the question how' you do
it how do you show your girl that you're
car Electra right now you're Anthony
like let's say you show up as car
Electra knock knock knock how how first
first I have it has to come from the
right body so let's say your car Electra
no no no no she wouldn't she wouldn't go
for car Electra like that she's older
now that's not her I bet you she looks
good but Anthony what if you're like you
hey you have to [__] Carri or else I
cannot come back oh that's a good
loophole like that I like that I would
have to be like I would have to be like
do a Lea today or some [__] oh D's hot
you know what I'm saying and then she'd
be like huh is she the hot chick who's
the hot chick right now she's a flavor
of the hot chick Zenia oh maybe she's
yeah but I don't know if we would all
say is she like the hot chick like like
the yeah I don't know who that is we
don't have Mar Robbie is at right now oh
yeah like the univers but she's been
around for for a while she has but she's
like cuz K was like sex symol hot her
Margo Robbie's like like hot but like
not sex symbol Hot she's like girlfriend
hot like car elra is like like drips
like with [__] sex and stuff yeah
well she had the whole milk campaign ER
you know mean do we have that then but
Margot Robbie was like Wolf of Wall
Street that's how the breakout happened
I think CU of social media now there's
like probably some Instagram or that you
know generation IG model yeah the
18-year-old some IG model probably it's
probably those chicks that's true cuz
they don't have the karma Electro types
anymore they all moov to only fans cuz
if Karma Electro was around today they'd
be like why don't you have an only fans
now it's got a pay wall we don't even
know who the [__] it is or even like
Ronda Rousey had a second right cuz
she's the badass and she's kind of hot
like we've always had like something
that was at least famous there's a Ronda
Rous you like those big old shoulders I
like Jack chicks it kind of makes sense
you like when she frowns in the camera
what do you think I want a little 100 lb
thing I think you would like be able to
match her in a way but I would be
dominated I don't even know why I said
that on camera
I would be dominated why did I do that I
would be dominated yeah why' your voice
be dominated
question brother we know you're a
corporate pain [__] dude he just turned
to a fat white boy he's trying to relate
to
me bringing it back to who's the hot
checkup today that a good question I
don't i' probably have to like do a leap
or something like that and then I I'd
show up and then I think because I'm
already like mindblowing her that I'm do
Lia I think there's like a open door how
do you say how do you tell her what do
you say so she knows that you're without
the Winking I'd be like yo I can't turn
back unless you [__] me but how does she
you got to have like some like inner
secret right like oh yeah there's hella
inner secet I'd be like dude on this day
this happened or remember I said this
and nobody else says this to you and why
do I even [__] know where you live
why would du alipa show up at your
[__] door that is true you know and
know the code to go into your door you
think knows you and the cats will know
the cats will some know cuz you'll have
all the like trigger points really I
think animals they smell your Fon I
think that's the first part that throws
you off but it's not like I'm a [__]
menacing giant I'm [__] doal they're
so old but they said the 20th hottest
females in Hollywood he's all the way
back there Scara Johansson Jessica be
true Jennifer Lawrence that's like Ouran
Fox I know they're not today yeah those
are still hot but that's our era stupid
we would body swap with women to try to
like trick our women into having lesbian
sex with us did you say genius and on
record my wife has been like I could
never be with a
woman I could never never okay fine
let's do good for the world wait you
know what I would do I would swap with
Michael Jordan and then I would do a
press conference and I would thank Steve
Green for inspiring me for
Myer I forgot about Kate up never got to
say Kate upt was me to say this [__]
about Hall of Fame speed Steve G [__]
inspired me every day part of the Jersey
dude imagine Michael Jord saying Steve
green
stuff and I would have an
or if we're trying to do good absolutely
so we like hopping into Biden oh [__]
yeah I'm buying some ankle braces right
you don't want to you don't want to mess
up while you're there maybe a waist
trainer yeah yeah what if you just
you're put on Jord you're put you're
making it fly yeah you're going to shoot
a couple Tik toks you're going to get
the youth involved yeah and maybe make
some like okay decisions
like I'm not a politician I don't know
how to fix the world but maybe you just
try I want to be inside a Biden just so
I can see how much I'm listening if I
can see like what people are saying
imagine you go in Biden and all of a
sudden your ears are like you have ear
muffs on you're like huh you just can't
hear [__] you just can't see [__]
say that's [__] crazy what I want to
shake the wrong person's hand I want to
fall I want to see how his life just
feels for some reason the inspiration
level started dropping yeah it did car
Electra sounds a little more fun yeah
let's stay let's stay on that one all
right next topic when you try to do good
it feels bad it just doesn't feel like
not even a human which animal would you
swap with and we're going to on next
time straight to beastiality huh just
kidding news careful voice is a brand
just kidding news is the man of smart
people the people of just kidding news
careful boys they are very smart just
kidding news the number one podcast in
the world
yeah